where do you go when saboteurs won the
third episode of Game of Thrones eighth
and final season the long night was all
sorts of intense and warning spoilers
ahead with the brutality and bloodshed
of the Battle of Winterfell nearly
taking out our Westerosi heroes and
letting the night King and his army of
whites and White Walkers roam free
but Arya Stark harnessed her inner ninja
evokes the spirit of azor Ahai and
turned the battle from a losing one to
an instant success when she stabbed the
night king and cut off his minions
lifeline in the process the side of the
Living when the Battle of Winterfell the
dead fell and so too did the long nights
and the Sun began to rise over
Winterfell once more so what comes next
with just three episodes of Game of
Thrones left and the perceived greatest
threat already eliminated how will
everyone move forward thankfully HBO
hasn't left fans totally in the lurch
after episode three the network released
a preview for the upcoming episode that
opposite taste of the events to come
after the Battle of Winterfell and boy
are they going to be wild in the teaser
Daenerys Targaryen fresh off learning
her lover Jon Snow is actually her
nephew and the true heir to the Iron
Throne states that the Great War is over
and last war is about to fall upon
Westeros what war might that be and what
will it entail oh you know just a casual
storming of the Westeros e capital of
King's Landing where Danny will send the
depleted army to march against the
reigning Queen Cersei Lannister the
Lannister lioness isn't going to go down
without a fight of course in the eyes of
many assert she has gone mad with power
and with grief over the loss of her
three children over the course of the
series she may not have dragons and
sullied soldiers the supports of very
many in Westeros all those elephants she
really really wanted but Cersei does
have someone who matches a hunger for
dominance
Joran Greyjoy he's got violence to spare
a fierce loyalty to Cersei motivated in
part by his desire to continue their
intimate relationship and no qualms
about killing sounds like a perfect
match for Cersei right Plus Cersei has
your own giant fleece and the Esso sell
sword force the golden company ringing
in at 20,000 strong she's not exactly
the underdog in this impending battle
still Daenerys and company aren't all
that worried about the fight Cersei and
Euron were put up in King's Landing the
mother of dragons makes it clear that
she and those who fought in the Battle
of Winterfell will win the last war
against Cersei and seating her from the
Iron Throne addressing those who
survived last episode's battle Dany
declares what the north will do to sir
see when they sack King's Landing rip
her out fruit and stem it probably won't
be all that simple and if and when
Cersei is booted from the throne
Daenerys wants so much it will be the
one to actually occupier at this point
the battle for the iron throne is
anyone's game Jon Snow whose real name
is Aegon Targaryen is technically the
rightful heir but he's never expressed
interest in ruling the Seven Kingdoms
his aren't Danny who is next in line to
the throne doesn't have a stronger claim
to power but once it's so much more and
would sacrifice everything to make her
dream a reality not only about my queen
some might tried to push Jon to accept
Dominion while others may try to strike
him down so the Dragon Queen can add
another title to her massive list the
same can be said for what people might
do with the Narus there also exists a
possibility that neither of them will
replace Ursa and someone else like say
Sansa will succeed the mad Queen it
isn't just a core conflict between the
powers in King's Landing and the forces
arriving from the north our fans have to
look forward to on the fourth episode of
Game of Thrones season 8 get ready for
some tense face offs Jaime will stand
against his sister after turning his
back on her during season 7 the Hound
will see his brother the mountain and
Daenerys will enter the room where her
father was killed while he sat on the
throne history might repeat itself in
two of these instances with Jaime going
from Kingslayer to Queens lair by ending
Circe's life and Dany being overcome by
her father's influence and slaughtering
her enemies without mercy she did it
before with some well tarly's brother
and father who's to say she won't do it
again when emotions run high in King's
Landing the long night is a tough act to
follow but all the pieces are in place
for the next episode of Game of Thrones
to be an all-time classic check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more loop of videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]